ب ا
[Silence]
الله اكبر الله اكبر اشهد لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان محمدا رسول
الله حي على
الصلاه حي على
الفلاح قد قامت
الصلاه قد قامت
الصلاه الله اكبر الله اكبر لا لا اله الا
الله استووا
اعتدلوا ساووا الصفوف سدوا
الفرج يت انذا لاذا
كبس
استوو الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين قل من يرزقكم
من السماوات والارض قل
الله وانا او اياكم لعلى هدى او في ضلال
مبين قل لا تسالون عما اجرمنا ولا نسال
عما
تعملون قل يجمع بيننا ربنا ثم يفتح بيننا
بالحق وهو الفتاح العليم
قل اروني الذين الحقت به
شركاء كلا بل هو الله العزيز
الحكيم وما ارسلناك الا
كافه للناس بشيرا
ونذيرا ولكن اكثر الناس لا
يعلمون الله
سميع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين ادنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين ويقولون متى هذا الوعد ان كنتم
صادقين قل لكم ميعاد يوم لا تستا اخرون
عنه ساعه ولا تستقدم
وقال الذين كفروا لن نؤمن بهذا القران ولا
بالذي بين
يديه ولو ترى اذ ولو ترى اذ المجرمون
ناكسوا رؤوسهم عند ربهم
ولو ترى اذ الظالمون في
غمرات ولو ترى اذ الظالمون موقوفون عند
ربهم يرجع بعضهم الى بعض
القول يقول الذين استضعفوا للذين استكبروا
لولا انتم لكنا
مؤمنين قال الذين استكبروا للذين استضعفوا
انحن صدد ناكم عن الهدى بعد اذ
جاءكم بل كنتم
مجرمين وقال الذين استضعفوا للذين
استكبروا بل مكر الليل
والنهار اذ
تامرون ان نكفر بالله ونجعل له
اندادا واسروا
الندامه لما راوا
العذاب وجعل لنا الاغلال في اعناق الذين
كفروا هل يجزون الا ما كانوا
يعملون الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
‏st
ا
[Silence]
استووا صلاه التراويح كتبكم
الله استووا
[Silence]
استو الله
اكبر
الله الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
وما ارسلنا في قريه من نذير الا قال
مترفوها انا بما ارسلتم به
كافرون وقالوا نحن اكثر اموالا واولادا
وما نحن بمعذبين قل ان ربي يبسط الرزق لمن
يشاء ويقدر ولكن اكثر الناس لا
يعلمون وما اموالكم ولا اولادكم بالتي
تقربكم عندنا زلفا الا من امن وعمل
صالحا الا من امن وعمل صالحا
فاولئك لهم جزاء الضعف بما عملوا وهم في
الغرفات
امنون والذين يسعون في ايات معاجزين اولئك
في العذاب
محضرون قل ان ربي يبسط الرزق لمن يشاء من
عباده ويقدر له وما انفقتم من شيء فهو
يخلفه وهو خير
الرازقين ويوم يحشرهم جميعا ثم يقول
للملائكه اهؤلاء
اياكم كانوا
يعبدون قالوا سبحانك انت ولينا من دونهم
بل كانوا يعبدون الجن اكثرهم بهم
مؤمنون فاليوم لا يملك بعضكم لبعض نفعا
ولا ضرا ونقول للذين ظلموا ذوقوا عذاب
النار التي كنتم بها
تكذبون واذا تتلى عليهم اياتنا بينات
قالوا ما هذا الا رجل يريد ان يصدكم عما
كان يعبد
اباؤكم وقالوا ما هذا الا افك مفترى وقال
الذين كفروا للحق لما
جاءهم ان هذا الا سحر
مبين وما اتيناهم من كتب
يدرسونها وما ارسلنا اليهم قبلك من
نذير وكذب الذين من قبلهم وما بلغوا معشار
ما
اتيناهم وكذب الذين من قبلهم وما بلغوا
معشار ما اتيناهم فكذبوا رسلي فكيف كان
نكير
قل انما اعظكم بواحده ان تقوموا لله مثنى
وفدا ثم
تتفكروا ما
بصاحبكم من
جنه ان هو الا نذير لكم بين يدي عذاب
شديد قل ما سالتكم من اجر فهو لكم ان اجري
الا على الله
وهو على كل شيء
شهيد قل ان ربي يقذف بالحق علام
الغيوب قل جاء الحق وما يبدئ الباطل وما
يعيد قل ان ضللت فانما اضل على
نفسي وان اهتديت فبما يوحي الي ربي انه
سميع
قريب ولو ترى اذ فزعوا فلا فوت واخذوا من
مكان قريب وقالوا امنا به وانا لهم
التناوش من مكان
بعيد وقد كفروا به من قبل ويقذفون بالغيب
من مكان
بعيد وحيل بينهم وما يشتهون كما فعل
باشياعهم من قبل
انهم كانوا في شك
مريب وحين بينهم وبينما يشتهون كما فعل
باشياعهم من قبل انهم كانوا في شك
مريب الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين الحمد لله فاطر السماوات والارض جاعل
الملائكه رسلا اولي اجنحه مثنى وثلاث
ورباع يزيد في الخلق ما
يشاء ان الله على كل شيء
قدير ما يفتح الله للناس من رحمه فلا ممسك
لها وما يمسك فلا مرسل له من بعده وهو
العزيز
الحكيم يا ايها الناس اذكروا نعمه الله
عليكم هل من خالق غير الله يرزقكم من
السماء والارض لا اله الا هو فانا
تؤفكون وان يكذبوك فقد كذبت رسل من قبلك
وان يكذبوك قد كذبت رسل من قبلك والى الله
ترجع
الامور يا ايها الناس ان وعد الله حق فلا
تغرنكم الحياه الدنيا ولا
يغرنكم بالله
الغرور ان الشيطان لكم عدو فاتخذوه
عدوا انما يدعو حزبه ليكونوا من اصحاب بال
السعير الذين كفروا لهم عذاب شديد والذين
امنوا وعملوا الصالحات لهم مغفره واجر
كبير افمن زين له سوء عمله فراه حسنا فان
الله يضل من يشاء ويهدي من
يشاء فلا تذهب نفسك عليهم حسرات ان الله
عليم بما
يصنعون والله الذي ارسل الرياح فتثير
سحابا فسقناه الى بلد ميت
فاحيينا فاحيينا به الارض بعد موتها كذلك
النشور من كان يريد العزه فلله العزه
جميعا
اليه يصعد الكلم الطيب والعمل الصالح
يرفعه والذين يمكرون السيئات لهم عذاب
شديد ومكر اولئك هو
يبور والله خلقكم من تراب ثم من نطفه ثم
جعلكم
ازواجا وما تحمل من انثى ولا تضع الا علمه
وما يعمر من معمر ولا ينقص من عمره الا في
كتاب ان ذلك على الله
يسير وما يستوي البحران هذا عذب فرات
سائغ شرابه وهذا ملح
اجاج ومن كل تاكلون لحما طريا وت تخرجون
حليه
تلبسونها وترى الفلك فيه مواخر لتبتغوا من
فضله ولعلكم
تشكرون يولج الليل في النهار ويولج النهار
في الليل وسخر الشمس والقمر كل يجري لاجل
مسمى وسخر الشمس والقمر كل يجري لاجل مسم
ذلكم الله ربكم له الملك والذين تدعون من
دونه ما يملكون من
قطمير ان تدعوهم لا يسمعوا
دعاءكم ولو سمعوا ما استجابوا لكم ويوم
القيامه يكفرون
بشرككم ولا ينبئك مثل
خبير يا ايها الناس انتم
الفقراء الى
الله والله هو الغني
الحميد الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله
[Silence]
الله
اكبر الله ال
ال الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
يا ايها الناس انتم
الفقراء الى الله والله هو الغني
الحميد ان يشاء يذهبكم ويات بخلق
جديد وما ذلك على الله
بعزيز و ولا تزر وازره وزر اخرى وان تدع
مثقله الى حملها لا يحمل منه شيء
ولو كان ذا قربى انما تنذر الذين يخشون
ربهم بالغيب واقاموا
الصلاه ومن تزكى فانما يتزكى لنفسه والى
الله
المصير وما يستوي الاعمى
والبصير ولا الظلمات ولا
النور ولا الظل ولا
الحرور وما يستوي
الاحياء ولا
الاموات ان الله يسمع من
يشاء وما انت بمسمع من في
القبور ان انت الا نذير انا ارسلناك بالحق
بشيرا ونذيرا وان من امه الا خل فيها
نذير ان يكذبوك فقد كذب الذين من قبلهم
جاءتهم رسلهم بالبينات وبالزبر
وبالكتاب
المنير ثم اخذت الذين كفروا فكيف كان
نكير الم تر ان الله انزل من
السماء ماء فاخرجنا به ثمرات مختلفا الوان
ومن الجبال جدد بيض وحمر مختلف الوانها
وغرابيب
سود ومن الناس
والدواب والانعام مختلف الوانه
كذلك انما يخشى الله من عباده
العلماء ان الله عزيز غفور
ان الذين يتلون كتاب الله واقاموا الصلاه
وانفقوا مما رزقناهم سرا
وعلانيه يرجون
تجاره يرجون تجاره لن
تبور ليوفيهم اجورهم
ويزيدهم من فضله انه غفور
شكور الذي اوحينا اليك من الكتاب هو الحق
مصدقا لما بين
يديه ان الله بعباده لخبير
بصير ثم اورثنا الكتاب الذين اصطفينا من
عبادنا فمنهم ظالم لنفسه ومنهم مقتصد
ومنهم سابق بالخيرات باذن الله
ذلك هو الفضل
الكبير جنات عدن يدخلونها يحلون فيها من
اساور من ذهب
ولؤلؤا ولباسهم فيها
حرير وقالوا الحمد لله الذي اذهب عنا
الحزن ان ربنا لغفور
شكور الذي احل لنا دار المقامه من فضله لا
يمسنا فيها نصب ولا يمسنا فيها
لغوب والذين كفروا لهم نار
جهنم لا يقضى عليهم فيموتوا ولا يخفف عنهم
من
عذابها كذلك نجزي كل كفور
كذلك نجزي كل كفور وهم يصطرخون فيها ربنا
اخرجنا نعمل صالحا غير الذي كنا نعمل اولم
نعمركم ما يتذكر فيه من تذكر
وجاءكم
النذير فذوقوا فما للظالمين من
نصير ان الله عالم غيب السماوات
والارض انه عليم بذات
الصدور الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر الله اكبر
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغ
عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين ان الله عالم غيب السماوات والارض
انه عليم بذات
الصدور هو الذي لكم خلائف في الارض فمن
كفر فعليه كفره ولا يزيد الكافرين كفرهم
عند ربهم الا مقتا ولا يزيد الكافرين
كفرهم الا
خسارا قل ارايتم
شركاءكم الذين تدعون من دون
الله اروني ماذا خلقوا من الارض ام لهم
شرك في السماوات ام اتيناهم كتابا فهم على
بينه منه بل ان يعد الظالمون بعضهم بعضا
الا
غرورا ان الله يمسك السماوات والارض ان
تزولا ولئن زالتا ان امسكهما من احد من
بعده انه كان حليما غفورا واقسموا بالله
جهد ايمانهم لئن جاءهم نذير ليكونن اهدى
من احدى الامم فلما جاءهم نذير ما زادهم
الا
نفورا
استكبارا في الارض ومكر السيء ولا يحيق
المكر السيء الا
باهله فهل ينظرون الا سنه
الاولين فلن تجد
لسنه الله تبديلا ولن تجد لسنه الله
تحويلا اولم يسيروا في الارض فينظروا كيف
كان عاقبه الذين من قبلهم وكانوا اشد منهم
قوه وما كان الله ليعجزه من شيء في
السماوات ولا في الارض انه كان حلي انه
كان عليما
قديرا ولو يؤاخذ الله الناس بما كسبوا ما
ترك على ظهرها من
دابه ولكن
يؤخرهم ولكن يؤخرهم الى اجل
مسما فاذا جاء اجلهم فان الله كان بعباده
بصيرا بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم
ياسين والقران الحكيم انك لمن المرسلين
على صراط
مستقيم تنزيل العزيز
الرحيم لتنذر قوما ما انذر
اباؤهم فهم
غافلون لقد حق القول على اكثرهم فهم لا
يؤمنون انا جعلنا في اعناقهم اغلالا فهي
الى الاذقان فهم
مقمحون وجعلنا من بين ايديهم سدا ومن
خلفهم سدا
فاغشيناهم فاغشيناهم فهم لا
يبصرون وسواء عليهم اانذرتهم
ام لم تنذرهم لا
يؤمنون انما تنذر من اتبع الذكر وخشي
الرحمن
بالغيب فبشره بمغفره واجر
كريم انا نحن نحيي الموتى ونكتب ما قدموا
واثارهم وكل شيء احصيناه في امام
مبين واضرب لهم مثلا اصحا القريه اذ جاءها
المرسلون اذ ارسلنا اليهم اثنين فكذبوهما
فعززنا بثالث فقالوا انا اليكم
مرسلون قالوا ما انتم الا بشر مثلنا وما
انزل الرحمن من شيء ان انتم الا
تكذبون قالوا ربنا يعلم ان اليكم
لمرسلون وما علينا الا البلاغ
المبين قالوا انا تطيرنا بكم لئن لم
تنتهوا لنرجمنكم
وليمسنكم منا عذاب
اليم قالوا
طائركم معكم ائن ذكرتم بل
انتم قالوا طا م معكم ائن ذكرتم بل انتم
قوم
مسرفون
وجاء من اقصى المدينه رجل يسعى قال يا قوم
اتبعوا
المرسلين اتبعوا من لا يسالكم اجرا وهم
مهتدون وما لي لا اعبد الذي فطرني واليه
ترجعون ا خذ من دونه الهه ان يردني الرحمن
بضر لا تغني عني شفاعتهم شيئا ولا
ينقذون اني اذا لفي ضلال
مبين اني امنت بربكم
فاسمعون قيل ادخل الجنه قال يا ليت قومي
يعلمون بما غفر ربي وجعلني من
المكرمين وما انزلنا على قومه من بعده من
جند من
السماء وما كنا
منزلين ان كانت الا صيحه واحده فاذا هم
خامدون يا حسره على
العباد ما ياتيهم من رسول الا كان به
يستهزئون الم يروا كم اهلكنا قبلهم من
القرون انهم اليهم لا
يرجعون وان كل لما جميع لدينا
محضرون الله
اكبر سميع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله
[Silence]
الحمد لله والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله
صلى الله عليه وعلى اله وصحبه
اجمعين ليله
القدر ان شاء الله
رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم ليله
القدر صلى الله عليه
وسلم عباده
بنت الله سبحانه
وتعالى امام
البخاري رحمه الله رسول الله صلى الله
عليه
وسلم لله الق
فتلاحى
رجلان فقال رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم ليله
القدر
رفع الله سبحانه وتعالى
رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم فعسى ان
يكون
خي صلى الله عليه وسلم
فالتمسوها السلام
عليكم رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسم
[Silence]
مسلم رحمه
الله ابو هريره رضي الله عنه رسول الله
صلى الله عليه
وسلم التمسوها
في العشر
الغوابر يعني ليله
القدر ليله
القدر حثم البخاري رحمه الله عائشه رضي
الله تعالى
عنها رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
التمسوها في الوتر من العشر الاواخر سيك
ليله القدر
29 امام البخاري رحمه الله المؤمنين رضي
الله تعالى
عنه رسول الله صل الله عليه
وسليله القدر ماء
وط
ضول الله
رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم فعسى ان
يكون
خيرا ليله
القدر لله
القدر ليله
القدر احمد رحمه الله
عدهن رضي الله
عنه صلى الله عليه وسلم منشن ليله القدر
صافيه
بلجه
ساجيه لا برد فيها ولا
حر الرسول صلى عليه وسلم س كان فيها قمر
ساطر not
لا يجوز
فيها لنجم ان يرم
به القدر
القدر رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وس بيضاء
شعا مسلم ابي بن كعب رحمه رضي الله
عنه are some
destion
be القدر القدر
قران رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم عبد الله بن عباس رضي الله عنه
قران اللوح
المحفوظ صلى الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
الله سبحانه
وتالى ليله
القدر
حسن رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم لات في
ل
[Silence]
صلى الله عليه وسلم الله سبحانه وت
ويسك الله سبحانه
وتعالى وصلى الله وسلم وبارك على نبينا
محمد وعلى اله وصحبه اجمعين وقوموا الى
صلاتكم ارحمكم الله
[Silence]
‏there
‏pleas
take other
[Silence]
شا
الله شاء
الله ان شاء الله
جك استقيموا واعتدلوا استوا سووا الصف سد
الخلل
الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
وايه لهم الارض الميته احييناها واخرجنا
منها حبا فمنه
ياكلون وجعلنا فيها جنات من نخيل
واعناب وفجرنا فيها من العيون لياكلوا من
ثمره وما عملته ايديهم افلا يشكرون
سبحان الذي خلق الازواج كلها مما تنبت
الارض ومن
انفسهم ومن
انفسهم ومما لا
يعلمون وايه لهم الليل نسلخ منه النهار
فاذا هم
مظلمون والشمس تجري لمستقر لها ذلك تقدير
العزيز العليم والقمر قدرناه منازل حتى
عاد كالعرجون
القديم لاشمس ينبغي لها ان تدرك القمر ولا
الليل سابق النهار وكل في فلك
يسبحون وايه لهم انا حملنا ذ ذريتهم في
الفلك
المشحون وخلقنا لهم من مثله ما
يركبون وان نشا نغرقهم فلا صريخ لهم ولا
هم
ينقذون الا رحمه منا ومتاعا الى حين واذا
قيل لهم اتقوا ما بين ايديكم وما خلف فكم
لعلكم
ترحمون وما
تاتيهم من ايه من ايات ربهم الا كانوا
عنها الا كانوا عنها
معرضين واذا قيل لهم انفقوا مما رزقكم
الله قال الذين كفروا للذين امنوا انطعم
لو يشاء الله
اطعمه ان انتم الا في ضلال
مبين ويقولون متى هذا الوعد ان كنتم
صادقين ما ينظرون الا صيحه واحده
تاخذهم تاخذهم وهم
يخصمون فلا يستطيعون
توصيه ولا الى اهلهم
يرجعون ونفخ في الصور فاذا هم من الاجداث
الى ربهم
ينسلون قالوا يا ويلنا من بعثنا من
مرقدنا هذا ما وعد الرحمن وصدق
المرسلون ان كانت الا صيحه
واحده فاذا هم فاذا هم جميع لدينا
محضرون فاليوم لا تظلم
نفس شيئا ولا تجزون الا ما كنتم
تعملون
ان اصحاب الجنه اليوم في شغل فاكهون
هم
وازواجهم في ظلال على
الارائك
متكئون لهم فيها
فاكهه ولهم ما
يدعون
سلام قولا من رب
رحيم
وامتاز اليوم ايها المجرمون
الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر بسم
الله الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين الم اعهد اليكم يا بني ادم الا
تعبدوا
الشيطان انه
لكم عدو مبين وان اعبدوني هذا صراط
مستقيم ولقد اضل منكم جبلا
كثيرا افلم تكونوا
تعقلون هذه
جهنم التي كنتم
توعدون اصلوها اليوم بما كنتم تكفرون
اليوم نختم على افواههم
وتكلمنا
ايديهم وتشهد ارجلهم بما كانوا
يكسبون ولو
نشاء لطمسنا على اعينهم فاستبقوا
الصراط
فاننا
يبصرون ولو نشاء لمسخ هم على
مكانتهم فما استطاعوا
مضيا ولا
يرجعون ومن
نعمره ننكسه في الخلق افلا
يعقلون وما علمناه الشعر وما ينبغي له ان
هو الا ذكر
وقران مبين لينذر وم كان حيا ويحق القول
على
الكافرين اولم يروا انا خلقنا لهم مما
عملت ايدينا انعاما فهم لها
مالكون
وذللناها لهم فمنها ركوبهم ومنها
ياكلون ولهم فيها منافع ومشارب افلا
يشكرون واتخذوا من دون الله الهه لعلهم
ينصرون لا
يستطيعون نصرهم وهم لهم
جند
محضرون فلا
يحزنك
قولهم انا نعلم ما يسرون وما ي نون اولم
يرى الانسان انا خلقناه من نطفه فاذا هو
خصيم
مبين وضرب لنا مثلا ونسي خلقه قال من يحيي
العظام وهي رميم قل يحييها الذي
انشاها اول مره وهو بك كل خلق عليم الذي
جعل لكم من الشجر الاخضر نارا نارا فاذا
انتم منه
توقدون اوليس الذي خلق السماوات والارض
بقادر على ان يخلق
مثلهم بلى وهو الخلاق العليم
انما امره اذا اراد شيئا ان يقول له كن
فيكون فسبحان الذي بيده ملكوت كل
شيء واليه
ترجعون بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم والصا
فات
صفا فالزاجرات
زجرا
فالتاليات ذكرا
انما الهكم
لواحد رب السماوات والارض وما بينهما ورب
المشارق
انا زينا
السماء بزينه
الكواكب انا زينا
السماء الدنيا بزينه
الكواكب وحفظ وحفظا من كل شيطان مارد لا
يسمعون الى الملا الاعلى ويقذفون من كل
جانب
دحورا ولهم عذاب
واصب الا من خط ف الخطفه فاتبعه شهاب ثاقب
فاستفتهم اهم اشد خلقا امن
خلقنا انا
خلقناهم من طين لازب بل عجبت
ويسخرون واذا ذكروا لا
يذكرون واذا راوا ايه يستسخرون
وقالوا ان هذا الا سحر
مبين ائذا متنا وكنا ترابا وعظاما ائا
لمبعوثون
اباؤنا
الاولون قل نعم
وانتم
داخرون فانما هي زجره
واحده فاذا هم
ينظرون وقالوا يا ويلنا هذا يوم
الدين هذا يوم الفصل الذي
كنتم به
تكذبون الله اكبر
سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
الله
اكبر
سبح الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد وا اياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين وقالوا يا ويلنا هذا يوم الدين هذا
يوم الفصل الذي كنتم به ت ذبون احشروا
الذين ظلموا
وازواجهم وازواجهم وما كانوا
يعبدون من دون الله فاهدوهم الى صراط
الجحيم وقفوهم انهم
مسؤولون ما لكم لا
تناصرون بل هم اليوم
مستسلمون واقبل بعضهم على بعض
يتساءلون قالوا
انكم كنتم تاتوننا عن اليمين قالوا بل لم
تكونوا مؤمنين وما كان لنا عليكم من سلطان
بل كنتم قوما
طاغين فحق علينا قول ربنا انا لذا ئ قون
فاغويناكم
انا كنا
غاوين فانهم يومئذ في العذاب
مشتركون انا كذلك نفعل
بالمجرمين
انهم كانوا اذا قيل لهم لا اله الا الله
يستكبرون ويقولون
انا
لتاركوا الهتنا لشاعر
مجنون بل جاء بالحق وصدق
المرسلين انكم
لذائقوا العذاب
الاليم وما تجزون الا ما كنتم
تعملون الا عباد الله المخلصين
اولئك لهم رزق معلوم
وفواكه وهم
مكرمون في جنات
النعيم على سرر
متقابلين يطاف عليهم بكاس من معين
بيضاء لذه
للشاربين لا فيها غول ولا هم عنها
ينزفون
وعندهم قاصرات الطرف
عين
كانهن بيض مكنون فاقبل بعضهم على بعض
يتساءلون قال
قائل منهم اني كان لي قرين يقول انك لمن
المصدقين ائذا متنا وكنا ترابا وعظاما ائا
لمدينون قال هل انتم
مطلعون فاطلع فراه في سواء
الجحيم قالت الله ان كت
لتردين ولولا نعمه ربي لكنت من
المحضرين افما نحن
بميتين الا موتتنا
الاولى وما نحن بمعذبين
ان هذا لهو الفوز العظيم لمثل هذا فليعمل
العاملون اذلك خير نزلا ام شجره
الزقوم انا جعلناها فتنه
للظالمين انها شجره تخرج في اصل
الجحيم طلعها كانه رؤوس
الشياطين فانهم
لاكلون منها فمالئون منها
البطون ثم ثم ان لهم عليها لشوبا من
حميم ثم ان مرجعهم لالى
الجحيم انهم الفوا
اباءهم
ضالين فهم على اثارهم
يهرعون ولقد ضل قبلهم اكثر الاول
ولقد ارسلنا فيهم
منذرين فانظر كيف كان عاقبه
المنذرين الا عباد الله
المخلصين ولقد نادانا نوح فلنعم
المجيبون
ونجيناه واهله من الكرب
العظيم واجعلنا
وجعلنا
ذريته هم
الباقين وتركنا عليه في
الاخرين سلام على نوح في
العالمين انا كذلك نجزي
المحسنين
انه من عبادنا
المؤمنين
ثم اغرقنا الاخ
ين الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر بسم
الله الحمد لله رب الع العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين وان من شيعته
لابراهيم اذ جاء ربه بقلب سليم اذ قال
لابيه وقومه ماذا تعبدون ائف كان
الهه ائف كان الهه دون الله تريدون فما
ظنكم برب
العالمين فنظر نظره في النجوم فقال ان
سقيم فتولوا عنه
مدبرين فراغ الى الهتهم فقال الا
تاكلون ما لكم لا
تنطقون فراغ عليهم ضربا
باليمين فاقبلوا اليه
يزفون قال اتعبدون ما
تنحتون والله خلقكم وما
تعملون قالوا ابنوا له بنيانا فالقوه في
الجحيم فارادوا به كيدا
فجعلناهم
الاسفلين وقال اني ذاهب الى ربي
سيهدين رب هب لي رب هب لي من
الصالحين فبش رناه بغلام حليم
فلما بلغ معه السعي قال يا بني قال يا بني
اني ارى في المنام اني اذبحك فانظر ماذا
ترى قال يا ابت افعل ما تؤمر ستجدني ان
شاء الله من الصاب ين فلما اسلما وت ل
للجبين
وناديناه اييا ابراهيم قد صدقت
الرؤيا انا كذلك نجزي
المحسنين ان هذا لهو البلاء المبين
وفديناه بذبح عظيم وتركنا عليه في
الاخرين سلام على
ابراهيم كذلك نجزي
المحسنين انه من عبادنا
المؤمنين
وبشرناه باسحاق
نبيا من
الصالحين وباركنا عليه وعلى
اسحاق ومن
ذريتهما محسن وظالم
لنفسه وظالم لنفسه مبين ولقد
مننا على موسى
وهارون
ونجيناهما وقومهما من الكرب
العظيم
ونصرناهم فكانوا هم
الغالبين
واتيناه الكتاب
المستبين و ديناه الصراط
المستقيم وتركنا عليهم في
الاخرين سلام على موسى
وهارون
انا كذلك نجزي
المحسنين
انهما من عبادنا
المؤمنين
وان الياس لمن المرسلين
اذ قال لقومه الا
تتقون اتدعون
بعلا وتذرون احسن
الخالقين الله ربكم ورب
ابائكم
الاولين فكذبوه
فانهم
لمحضرون الا عباد الله
المخلصين وتركنا عليه في
الاخرين سلام على
الياسين انا كذلك نجزي
المحسنين
انه من عبادنا
المؤمنين
وان لوطا لمن
المرسلين اذ نجيناه واهله اجمعين
الا عجوزا في
الغابرين
ثم دمرنا
الاخرين وانكم لتمرون عليهم
مصبحين
وبالليل افلا
تعقلون الله اكبر
سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
شافع
الوط st
‏pleas
first
the الله
سبحانه الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعم انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين سبح اسم ربك الاعلى
الذي خلق
فسوى والذي قدر
فهدى والذي اخرج
المرعى
فجعله
غثاء
احوى سنقرئك فلا
تنسى الا ما
شاء الله
انه يعلم الجهر وما
يفا ونيسرك
لليسرى فذكر ان نفعت
الذكرى
سيذكر من
يغشى
ويتجنبها
الاشقى الذي يصلى
النار
الكبرى ثم لا يموت فيها ولا
يحيا قد افلح من
تزكى وذكر اسم
ربه
فصلى بل تؤثرون الحياه
الدنيا
والاخره
خير
وابقى ان هذا
في الصحف
الاولى صحف
ابراهيم
وموسى الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر الله اكبر
اكبر الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عل عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين بسم
الله
للاف
قريش ال
فهم رحله
الشتاء
والصيف
فليعبدوا رب هذا
البيت الذي
اطعمهم من جوع
وامنهم من
خوف الله اكبر
سميع
الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
‏spel
frs please the first line
second الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين بسم الله ال
قل هو الله
احد الله
الصمد لم يلد ولم
يولد ولم يكن له كفوا
احد الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده اللهم انت الحق ووعدك الحق ولقاؤك
الحق وجنه الحق وساعه الحق ونار الحق ونبي
حق ونبينا محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم حق
اللهم بك اسلمنا وعليك توكلنا ويك نبنا
وبك خاصمنا فاغفر لنا ما قدمنا وما اخرنا
فانت المقدم وانت الموخر وانت على كل شيء
قدير اللهم اهدنا في من هديت وعافنا في من
عافيت وتولنا في من توليت وبارك لنا فيما
اعطيت وكنا واصرف عنا برحمتك شر ما قضيت
انك تقضي ولا يقضى عليك انه لا يزل من
واليت ولا يعز من عاديت تباركت ربنا
وتعاليت اللهم اغفر لنا ذنوبنا اللهم اغفر
لنا ذنوبنا اللهم اغفر لنا ذنوبنا وان لم
تغفر لنا وترحمنا لونن من
الخاسرين اللهم انك عفو تحب العفو فعفو
عنا اللهم انك عفو تحب العفو فاعف عنا
اللهم انك عفو كريم تحب العفو فاعف عنا
اللهم اعتق رقابنا من النار ورقاب والدينا
وذريتنا
وازواجنا
وارحمنا وامهاتنا
وابائنا
واخواننا اخل جنه مع
الابرار يا عزيز يا
غفار يا حي يا قيوم يا حي يا قيوم يا حي
يا قيوم برحمتك
استغيث اصلح لنا شاننا كله ولا تكلنا الى
انفسنا طرفه
عين اللهم يا سامع الصوت ويا سابق الفوت
ويا كاس عذام م لح من بعد الموت اغفر
لجميع الموتى المسلمين الذين شهدك
بالوحدانيه ونبيك بالرساله وماتوا على ذلك
اللهم اغفر لهم وارحمهم وعافهم وعفو عنهم
واكرم نزلهم ووسع مدخلهم واغسلهم بالماء
الثلج
والبرد ونقيه من الذنوب والخطايا كما ينق
الثوب الابيض من
التناس ومتعنا اللهم
باسماعنا
وابصارنا وقواتنا ابدا ما احييتنا واجعله
الوارث منا واجعلنا واجعل ثرنا على من
ظلمنا وانصرنا على من عادانا ولا تسلط
علينا بذنوبنا من لا يخافك فينا ولا
يرحمنا اللهم عز جارك وجل ثناؤك وتقدست
اسماؤك اللهم لا يرد امرك ولا يحزن جندك
سبحانك وبحمدك اللهم اد المسجد الاقصى الى
رحاب المسلمين اللهم اد المسجد الاقصى الى
رحاب المسلمين وارزقنا فيه صلاه قبل
الممات اللهم عليك باليهود
والنصارى اللهم انصر الاسلام والمسلمين
اللهم انصر الاسلام والمسلمين اللهم انصر
اخواننا المستضعفين في كل مكان خاصه خص في
القز فلسطين وفي سودان وفي السين وفي
كشمير وفي الهند وفي كل مكان
اللهم ادهم جنودك لا يعلم جنودك الا انت
اللهم اللهم زل الشرك والمشركين ودمر
اعداء الدين يا كوي يا
عزيز اللهم تقبل صيامنا اللهم تقبل صيامنا
اللهم تقبل صيامنا اللهم تقبل قيامنا
اللهم تقبل قراننا وصلاتنا وصدقنا وزكاتنا
يا رب
العالمين اللهم اجعل قران حجه لنا ولا حجه
علينا يا رب العالمين اللهم ذكرنا منهما
نسينا وعلمنا منهما جهلنا وارزقنا تلاوه
اناء الليل واطراف النهار على وجهك الذي
يرك عن النار يا رب
العالمين اللهم تقبل منا انك انت السميع
العليم وتب علينا يا م التواب الرحيم وصلى
الله على محمد وعلى اله وصحبه اجمعين
برحمتك يا ارحم الراحمين اللهم
امين الله
[Silence]
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
‏m
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله